Hey! Come in Shawn.
Thank you, Mr. Merchan.
How's it going?
Good. How are you?
Good, good, good.
I've called you in here for a few things.
Here, take a seat.
I've called you in here for a few reasons.
As you know, we're doing our quarterly review.
And I've just been going through this checklist here of your reports and that,...
...and, you know, we're pretty satisfied with your performance.
You're here on time every day,...
...you've been working well with others,...
...I mean, you know, people seem to like working with you,...
...and you know, you get your stuff done.
You know, everything's here.
We have been having a slight issue with your TPS report.
You know, we're gonna need you to come in on Saturday and play a little catch up...
...since the reports haven't been up to standard.
You're getting check minuses.
I think it's such a good idea.
That is a terrible idea.
No one's asking you.
We really need to set up a shop in Cambodia.
It's a huge market.
All the numbers are here.
What do you guys think of opening a shop in Cambodia?
Well, it's something we should think about.
But I think we should go over the numbers, one more time maybe.
What do you think?
If the numbers show promise for the future of the company and the rest and then at least...